este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a das
link las line es una herramienta de
seguridad todo-en-uno que te permite
generar contraseñas seguras almacenar
las guardar tu información personal y de
pago guardar notas de forma segura
proteger tu privacidad todo de forma
rápida y precisa riadas line puntocom
barra visual polític s y descárgate lo
de forma totalmente gratuita además
usando el código visual político que
podrás probar la versión premium
totalmente gratis durante 30 días y
luego además si decides continuar con
ella tendrás un 10 por ciento de
descuento
[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos corea del sur es uno de los
países más libres y democráticos de asia
y también uno de los más conectados y
tecnológicamente avanzados del mundo
seguro que no es algo que te sorprenda
el contraste con su empobrecido y
tiránico vecino del norte es más obvio
que la diferencia entre la noche y el
día y de hecho aquí en visual político
ya os hemos hablado en varios vídeos
sobre algunas de estas diferencias sin
embargo espera un momento porque en esta
ocasión no os vamos a hablar de cómo es
la economía surcoreana ni de su
vertiginoso desarrollo orientado al
mercado ni de nada por el estilo en este
vídeo vamos a hablar de internet seguro
que en alguna ocasión habéis oído hablar
de corea del sur como el país más top a
nivel mundial en conexiones online
fijaos
corea del sur es el país del mundo con
más usuarios conectados a redes de fibra
óptica casi el 31 por ciento de toda la
población además el 96 por ciento de los
surcoreanos tienen acceso a internet lo
que también representa el mayor
porcentaje del planeta asimismo son los
terceros mayores usuarios de redes
sociales ni más ni menos que el 85% de
los surcoreanos las utilizan
regularmente para que os hagáis una idea
en eeuu el porcentaje se queda en el 70%
y en reino unido y canadá en apenas el
67 por ciento y ahí no queda todo
también es el país que hoy por hoy
comercializar la mayor velocidad de
internet dos gigas y medio de bajada que
pronto llegarán a ser 10
y por si fuera poco es el país con mayor
penetración de smartphones del mundo el
94 por ciento de los surcoreanos tienen
uno
ah
en otras palabras que con el sur está
más conectado que un enchufe pero por si
todo esto no os parece suficiente aún
hay más datos corea del sur claro cuenta
con la red 4g más implementado del mundo
y ha sido uno de los primeros países en
comercializar el ahora tan famoso 5g
pero bueno vale si es verdad basta ya de
tanto datos creo que todo esto ha
quedado bastante claro no os parece
corea del sur es un país con un gran
desarrollo tecnológico y un mercado
teleco envidiable pero amigos tal y como
nos gusta decir en visor político es por
hace un momento porque no es oro todo lo
que reluce
[Música]
según la ong freedom house que realiza
anualmente un índice de referencia sobre
la libertad en la red con el sur apenas
está clasificada como parcialmente libre
en 2018 consiguió una puntuación de 36
sobre 100 es decir al mismo nivel que
países como nigeria aunque lista no
vamos como todo el mundo sabe
democracias ejemplares
[Música]
pero entonces la pregunta que seguro
seguro te surge pero qué diantres pasa
en corea del sur porque tiene un nivel
de libertad en la red tan bajo pues hoy
en visual político vamos a desgranar un
problema no tan conocido de este país
como el gobierno quiere tener el control
total de internet
una tradición de censura
no nos engañemos todos los países tienen
sus luces y sus sombras y por supuesto
con el sur no es un caso diferente
la joven democracia surcoreana que
apenas arrancó en 1988 es todavía una
democracia imperfecta a lo largo de su
corta vida y sin excepciones todos y
cada uno de los presidentes democráticos
han tenido una clara tendencia a la
censura y al control de la información
ya sea por falta de cultura política o
por cuestiones morales y culturales
ligadas a su pasado confucionista el
estado sigue siendo a día de hoy muy
pero que muy paternalista y la visión de
la sociedad es piramidal es decir en
otras palabras a los mayores y a los
jefes no se les discute nada
además hay un fuerte sentido de
comunidad frente a las sociedades más
individualistas y menos rígidas de
occidente
esta realidad es la que explica que los
líderes del país se habían sentido
legitimados para controlar ciertos
aspectos
muchas veces demasiados de la vida de la
gente y también para limitar la
capacidad de expresarse libremente todo
esto claro en nombre del bien común lo
que no pocas ocasiones no significa otra
cosa que controlar la libertad de
expresión y por supuesto limitar la
crítica al gobernante o partido político
de turno sin embargo amigos hay dos
temas por encima de todos los demás que
el gobierno utiliza para justificar
todas estas acciones de censura la
protección contra corea del norte y la
moral pública que será eso de la moral
pública
para llevar a cabo todas estas acciones
el gobierno recurre a la ley de
seguridad nacional una ley que entre
otras cosas prohíbe en la práctica el
comunismo cualquier declaración en favor
de corea del norte o ideas subversivas
que alimenten la idea de acabar o
enfrentarse con el estado cojo porque
esta ley no se aplica sólo en el terreno
físico sino también en la red por
ejemplo mediante el bloqueo o cierre de
las páginas que hablen a favor del
régimen norteño y luego en segundo lugar
hay otro factor clave que últimamente
está cobrando cada vez más y más
importancia la prohibición de lo que se
ha venido a conocer cómo no por amigos
lo habéis escuchado bien corea del sur
es uno de los pocos países del mundo
donde está explícitamente prohibida esta
actividad lo que se conoce como no por
concretamente desde el año 2008 bueno
eso y también un montón de juegos de
azar y muchísimos juegos online bajo el
pretexto de ser webs y aplicaciones y
presentes
pero no os creáis que esto es algo nuevo
para nada fijaos hace ya algunos años
entre el 2001 y el 2003 el entonces
gobierno del centroizquierdista premio
nobel de la paz- king the sound se
dedicó a bloquear como si no hubiera
mañana webs de contenido homosexual por
considerarlas literalmente espacios de
obscenidad y perversión casi nada ahora
bien claro si quieres ser capaz de
llevar a cabo toda esta censura como
dios manda
es decir si quieres hacer bien las cosas
y ser un auténtico rodillo entonces
necesitas organizarte
[Aplausos]
precisamente por eso en 2008 el
presidente conservador lee myung bak
creó un organismo público que se encarga
de controlar internet la comisión de
estándares de comunicaciones de corea
hola café sc
vamos a un función ya mi hijo son dos
esta comisión tiene el poder de bloquear
y hasta de cerrar páginas web sin
necesidad siquiera de conseguir una
orden judicial
[Música]
el problema amigos es que en lugar de
avanzar hacia un internet cada vez más
libre de corea del sur parece estar
retrocediendo a toda velocidad
las cifras más recientes de 2017 sobre
webs bloqueadas y eliminadas por la
cárcel sc son sencillamente
espeluznantes casi 67 mil 67 mil webs
fueron bloqueadas y más de 15 mil fueron
eliminadas en un solo año vamos que
cualquiera diría que todo esto se les
está yendo de las manos amigos qué miedo
va a haber a políticos bloquear y cerrar
webs a su antojo no os parece
[Música]
y ojos 2017 fue el primer año desde el
2008 cuando empezó a funcionar la
comisión en que se redujo un poco el
número de páginas bloqueadas y
eliminadas o sea que encima fue un buen
año tela pero llegados a este punto la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es cómo se
censura el internet en corea del sur
hasta dónde es capaz de llegar el
gobierno para evitar que lo inmoral
llegue a la población y tal vez la
pregunta más importante podría ser
visual político considerado un canal
inmoral pues bien veámoslo
un entramado censor independiente
amigos la realidad es que la censura en
la raíz en cora del sur es algo muy pero
que muy serio y no precisamente algo
transparente
fijaos la clave está en la que acs que
os he comentado hace un momento esta
comisión que se dice independiente se
enmarca dentro de otra la comisión de
comunicaciones de corea o kfc lacaze sc
regula internet y la caf se regula todos
los medios de comunicación y la pregunta
clave cómo funcionan
ah
pues veréis la cárcel tiene cinco
miembros de los cuales dos los deciden
directamente el presidente surcoreano
entre ellos su director los otros tres
son decididos por la asamblea nacional
el parlamento del país vamos lo que se
dice un órgano no politizado pero más
independiente
lacaze sc la comisión que regula
internet se dedica a identificar webs
que violen alguna ley como pueden ser
las webs pero norcoreanas las de
pornografía o de juego online pero
también lo que el organismo considere
ciber difamación o contenido anti
militar es entonces cuando se emite una
petición de borrado de contenido bloqueo
o cierre total de la web a la cárcel efe
que a su vez la transmite al prestador
de servicios de medios que deberá
cumplir la orden y amigos en muy rara
ocasión se rechazó una petición de este
tipo aunque eso sí formalmente el
prestador de servicios de medio pueden
recurrir la decisión en un plazo de 15
días pero lo cierto es que pasado el
plazo es la propia cárcel sc quien
decide que sanciones y castigos
aplicarán en función de la ley del
contenido del que se trate sin que
ningún juez actúe en ningún momento del
proceso que os parece a nosotros la
verdad es que nos vuelve demasiado
censura a diestro y siniestro y claro
esto choca con los fundamentos de la
libertad y la democracia
sin embargo en 2017 llegó al poder un
nuevo presidente el abogado por los
derechos humanos muy chain consiguió el
poder tras un turbio escándalo de
corrupción protagonizado por su
predecesora conservadora bácum en muchos
medios del mundo occidental le pintaron
como todo un reformista que traería
nuevos aires al país pero realmente está
siendo así en el campo de la libertad en
internet pues no ya se adelantó que no
atentos
[Música]
mountain mano dura con cara bonita
lo habéis visto aquí en visual político
en un pasado vídeo fuimos muy críticos
con un change por su gestión económica
pero qué ocurre en el campo de las
libertades individuales y concretamente
en internet al fin y al cabo hablamos de
un político de centroizquierda que se ha
esforzado mucho en transmitir la idea de
que corea del sur ha superado una oscura
etapa de corrupción tras los escándalos
de su predecesor aparte
[Música]
y lo hizo con una tremenda campaña de
lavado de imagen con tintes bastantes
populistas por cierto que logró que su
aprobación entre los surcoreanos a
principios de su mandato supera se la
escalofriante cifra del 80 80 por ciento
vamos todo un fervor popular
además los diálogos con corea del norte
y sus cumbres con kim jong-un le
ayudaron un montón en esto de ser visto
como un hombre de paz y de
reconciliación dentro y fuera de corea
pero un momento es todo tan bonito como
lo pintan pues lo cierto es que no si su
gestión económica ya está dejando
bastante pero que bastante que desear en
materia de libertades individuales y de
libertad de la red pues tampoco está
haciendo nada pero que nada bueno la
censura es un consenso bipartidista en
corea del sur así es amigos según un
reporte del zoom gun hill bo uno de los
tres mayores periódicos de corea del sur
la censura en la era de mundo se ha
ampliado aún más en el terreno político
por ejemplo el gobierno de mus les
retiró recientemente la financiación al
único zintan que en eeuu especializado
en temas coreanos el ibex y corean
instituir el motivo pues no penséis que
tuvo nada que ver con la austeridad ni
nada por el estilo sino con ser crítico
con las actitudes digamos demasiado
amistosas de munt con kim jong-un y su
régimen en corea del norte
el think tank coreano en una universidad
de eeuu cerrará tras retirar según la
financiación
[Música]
el problema claro no es que le retirar
la financiación a un tanque en
washington sino esa idea de utilizar el
dinero público para premiar a los amigos
y castigar a los críticos ahora bien no
penséis que hay termina todo para nada
lo más grave y lo que más preocupa a la
comunidad internacional es la nueva
forma de censura que el gobierno del
mundo ha implementado en internet se
considera una especie de censura al
estilo chino por ser el mismo método que
emplea pekín para bloquear páginas web
que si lo habéis escuchado bien corea
del sur- copiando a china en materia de
libertades desde este mismo año 2019 el
gobierno surcoreano ha comenzado a abrir
los paquetes de datos procedentes de los
servidores en webs encriptadas https
consideradas las más seguras
lacaze este bloqueo en febrero 895
páginas web con este método basado en el
espionaje del sn y método que por cierto
prohíbe la ley coreana una de las webs
bloqueadas con este método ha sido por
ejemplo la mayor web no por del mundo
pero ahora bien cómo funciona pues
fijaos si el usuario trata de acceder
a una web https considerada por el
gobierno como dañina la café sc abre los
paquetes de datos para averiguar el
servidor cuya información no está
encriptada de esta forma conociendo el
servidor el gobierno puede bloquear el
acceso
[Música]
pero eso no es todo si el gobierno da
con la clave para desencriptar la
información podría incluso ver
concretamente lo que visitas en internet
y acceder a información personal como
tulipe en pocas palabras el gobierno de
mont podría estar espiando cada paquete
de datos que reciben los internautas
surcoreanos para bloquear el acceso si
se trata de una página no permitida es
decir controlar que hacen internet cada
persona privacidad qué es eso de la
privacidad
y todo esto amigos creo que no hace
falta ni decirlo no es propio de
regímenes libres ni democráticos ni
desde luego de líderes con la imagen de
conciliadores como la que tiene mundo en
visual político nos encanta corea del
sur y creemos que es un país ejemplar en
la mayoría de los aspectos y
precisamente porque nos encanta estamos
preocupados por esta falta de libertad
en la red por eso os animamos mucho a ir
a corea del sur un lugar increíble
aunque eso sí si queréis disfrutarlo del
todo quedaos conmigo o un momento con
dash line podrás sacarle todo el partido
al rapidísimo internet surcoreano sin
las limitaciones de las que os hemos
hablado en este vídeo porque amigos das
link es una herramienta de seguridad
todo-en-uno que incluye una vpn para
todos tus dispositivos de tal forma que
puedas usar redes públicas de manera
segura y anónima
seguro que a ti al igual que a mí
también te preocupa tu privacidad en la
red pues bien con daschle y mantendrá su
identidad online segura das link de
proteger a de todo tipo de amenazas
contra tu identidad ya sabéis que hay
muchos hackers ahí fuera pensando en
cómo aprovecharse de ti y la mejor forma
de esquivar los es utilizando daschle
también hacen una cosa muy interesante
llamada monitoreo de la edar web que
consiste en escanear la web en busca de
datos personales filtrados o robados a
alertando tal instante en caso de que
tus datos personales se encuentren donde
no deben de tal forma claro que puedas
tomar medidas rápidamente y por supuesto
das link también te ayudará a generar
contraseñas seguras y cada vez que una
web te quiera introducir las te ayudará
a rellenar los campos requeridos de
forma rápida y sencilla es súper cómodo
se acabó eso de no acordarse de las
contraseñas como os decía antes das link
es totalmente gratuita pero hay algunas
opciones premium en caso de que quieras
disponer de más servicios
bien pues si entras en daschle puntocom
visual polític s usando el código visual
político ese tendrás una prueba de estas
opciones premium totalmente gratis
durante 30 días y si después además
decides continuar con ellas obtendrás
10% de descuento a la hora de contratar
las de verdad no lo dudes hazme caso y
entra en el link que te hemos dejado en
la descripción y descarga te das link de
forma gratuita no te arrepentirás
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
ah